okay so the topic of this video today
are some of the various patterns that
exist in evolution so let's go ahead and
get started
so let's jump right into something
called divergent evolution this is
defined as when closely related species
over time become increasingly different
you know a great example that you're
probably already familiar with
especially if you're in my class are the
finches the Darwin finches on the
Galapagos Islands you might know that
each Island has a little different
habitats and and food for the finches to
eat and so they've all adapted to eat
various different kinds of foods and you
can see that in their beaks well this is
a great example of divergent evolution
let's kind of trace them back in time
here so here's a picture of South
America and in the red box off the
western coast of Ecuador in the red box
is the Galapagos Islands and so it's
believed that here's a bunch of
cartoonish birds are representing the
ancestral finches it's believed that a
group of of these finches arrived to the
Galapagos Islands from the mainland of
South America let's zoom on it and so
here we are looking at an overhead kind
of a satellite image of the Galapagos
Islands here and each finch eventually
adapted to the differing environments on
the islands so as time passed you
imagine the finches reproduced and then
eventually some of them might fly
elsewhere looking for better food and
more food better habitats to live and
and so now a small group has arrived at
this island over time they're gonna
multiply of course and then as time
passes maybe a small group migrates over
to this island and as time passes
they're gonna multiply and every island
is a little you has some uniqueness to
them and as time passes they start to
acquire or they start to take on the
characteristics and the adaptations to
suit
this particular environment but as time
passes you imagine others will migrate
and once they get to the new island they
multiply and reproduce and they start to
adapt
this particular island and as time
passes again this process continues as
time passes some will migrate and
they'll start to reproduce and they'll
start to adapt to this island and it's
worth noting that today there are over
thirty there are 13 different species of
Darwin finches on the various islands of
the Galapagos and but it's really
interesting to see how they've diverged
from one original ancestor species back
in the mainland of South America where
is a neat little example here we have
some cartoon squirrels but these
actually are representing real squirrels
in in the Grand Canyon area so right now
we're going back in time here when the
Grand Canyon wasn't so grand and right
now there's gene flow between the
northern squirrels which represent the
left of the animation and the southern
squirrels which would represent the
right of the animation but as time
passes eventually we have our Grand
Canyon forces of erosion and the
Colorado River carving and making the
Grand Canyon what it is today and right
now today you can see that there's
absolutely no gene flow between the
squirrels on the Left representing the
northern side and on the right
representing the southern side and for
instance here we have two different
species of squirrels they've diverged
over the years because they've been
geographically isolated there's been no
gene flow between the squirrels in the
northern rim and the squirrels in the
southern rim because there's a physical
barrier separating them there's no gene
flow and over time they've each adapted
to their own unique environment great
example here of divergent evolution and
so the pattern that we can kind of take
from this is that species will adapt to
the environment where they ultimately
live and over time will begin to acquire
any and adapt to the characteristics of
that area
well let's go ahead and switch the page
here to convergent evolution this is
where different species over time will
evolve similar traits because they live
in a similar environment probably one of
the more visual examples are these right
here you know tuna representing fish a
dolphin representing mammals and a
penguin representing birds well you
think about what's in common between
them is their environment there these
are all ocean organisms here aquatic
marine organisms here and notice how
they all have similar traits even though
they're very distantly related again the
tuna is a fish the dolphin is a mammal
and the penguin is a bird these are very
very different animals and yet because
they live in the same environment the
ocean whether you're a fish a mammal or
a bird it is an advantage to have a
smooth streamlined body with flippers to
help you navigate through the ocean
water
notice how the appearance of these
organisms is coming together it's
converging now am i implying that
sometime in the future fish like tuna
and dolphins and penguins will converge
and become one species are they becoming
the same species and the answer is
absolutely not so kind of another fun
example of convergent evolution would be
for instance these critters right here
flying squirrels well you might know
squirrels are in the rodent category so
they're in the same category as like
mice and rats and other rodents
well another organism called a sugar
glider when you first look at sugar
gliders and fly in squirrels you would
think wow these things are very closely
related they resemble one another they
each have little skin flaps in between
their their front legs and back legs for
them to kind of glide and fly through
the air but the sugar gliders are
marsupials which if you know that word
that's the same category as kangaroos so
they're actually not very closely
related at all yet they have converged
on this appearance because it helps them
survive in there and
and so kind of the the pattern here the
takeaway is this is that if different
species live in similar environments
they tend to develop the common features
that would allow them to survive in that
environment so let's kind of move on to
the next topic right here coevolution
two or more species evolve in response
to changes in one another kind of the
classic example is what you kind of see
right here the relationship between
birds and like like the hummingbirds in
the picture and the flowers notice the
beaks and the hummingbirds kind of
perched on the branches of those trees
see how long those hummingbird beaks are
well notice how there is the bird at the
bottom that's feeding on a flower tube
that's equally as long and so the
hummingbirds will will benefit by
getting food from the from the flowers
they will feed off of the nectar that's
inside of the flower
well how does the flower benefit the
flower benefits by by reproduction as
the the birds fly from flower to flower
to flower they spread pollen and allow
the flowers to reproduce kind of a neat
kind of a classic example here of
coevolution the two have evolved in
response to one another kind of another
fun example are what's called an
evolutionary arms race if you're
familiar with the term in arms race you
might think of like the Cold War era
United States versus the Soviet Union
and the the back and forth that each
country went through in order to build
weaponry to defeat the other if there
was ever a war between the two but this
is what's called an evolutionary arms
race you know here is the kind of a
complex pattern here of a murex snail
shell notice all the the branchings and
and the the twisted shapes to it well
that helps to prevent allow it to kind
of survive crabs crabs will eat snails
well in order to adapt to this notice
how the crabs have evolved big big
pincers to crack the shells so they're
kind of evolving back and forth in an
arms race in order to kind of survive
the presence of the other kind of a neat
little example there of Cove
Ellucian but what it shows is kind of a
pattern that the evolution of one
species can affect others
so another pattern that we see in
evolution is extinction life eventually
species will eventually die off and and
once they're gone they're gone
well when it comes to extinction let's
talk about the background extinctions
these are the extinctions that are less
severe they tend to happen at a local
level it's not a global worldwide
catastrophe but for instance maybe a
forest fire starts in an area and as a
result of the devastation from the
forest fire a species of plant might
become extinct but there's other reasons
for these I would have called background
extinctions for instance the dodo bird
went extinct when pigs and cats were
introduced into the area where they used
to live and the dodo bird was preyed
upon same with this sea cow right here
it was hunted for its fur and from the
oil that you can get from its fat and so
unfortunately due to predation it was it
became extinct and the Tasmanian wolf
this wanted stink because of competition
it was unable to compete with dogs that
were introduced to its area where it
used to live so but these are what we
examples of background extinctions
because despite their loss the rest of
the biodiversity in the area the rest of
the ecosystems were relatively
unaffected well then there's the mass
extinctions these are the the severe
global level extinction events that have
occurred throughout Earth's history
there have been at least five mass
extinctions that have occurred
throughout history the most recent one
being about 65 million years ago in the
map the little green area is what's
called the Yucatan Peninsula off the
coast of Mexico there and that X kind of
marks the spot where we believe a large
impact occurred from outer space and
when you see the this image here of the
crater again this is under the surface
of the ocean but you still see that
there's a crater sized hole there
that was left behind and we believe that
that was the impact site that ended the
the the age of the dinosaurs 65 million
years ago well how do we know that a
mass extinction might have occurred well
normally when you're looking through the
layers of rock you know randomly you'll
find fossils here and there but let's
pretend this area of rock right here is
65 million year old rock what we see are
just a lot of fossils in that area of
the rock and then no more fossils in the
younger areas so clearly whatever that
species is has gone extinct now when we
look at other forms of life again you
kind of see a random fossil here or
random fossil there but then when you
get to the 65 million year old rock you
just see a lot of fossils and then no
more fossils in the younger layers
implying that that species is now
extinct and again in the case of the
dinosaurs a random dinosaur fossil here
a random fine dinosaur fossil there but
when you look at 65 million year old
rock this is the time when the dinosaurs
went extinct we find a lot of dinosaur
fossils and then no more fossils in the
younger layers so clearly some kind of
mass extinction event happened here
especially when you look at 65 million
year old rocks around the entire world
and you see kind of the same pattern you
know there are there are many experts
that would argue that humans are the
cause of a sixth mass extinction
occurring right now and you think of all
the reasons for that well one of the
leading reasons would be deforestation
and the destruction of natural habitats
is causing life around the world to go
extinct
let's not forget the effects that
climate change has for instance on the
the coral reefs and the bleaching that
they caused the different varieties of
not just water pollution but also air
pollution and all of these have had an
impact over the past few decades that
has caused a lot of life to go extinct
well it's kind of finish up on the rate
of evolution you know how fast is
evolution occurred well there is no
exact timeframe there's a couple
patterns after all these notes are
called patterns of evolution so the
first pattern is kind of the most common
one the pattern called gradualism slow
and steady change of one species over
the time for instance here we have a
horse and we're gonna see as small
changes continually build when we look
at fossils millions of years ago horses
when we see their fossils and compare
them to horses today they're just
incredibly smaller now just to give you
a little bit of context if I put that
horse on the surface next to the 60
million year old horse you can see
there's quite the size difference there
but horses have gradually evolved over
the years to be what they are today but
we see slow and steady changes
intermediate step by step by step until
what we see today that's in a great
example right there of gradualism well
then there's another pattern called
punctuated equilibrium and this is the
pattern of a rapid change rapid
evolution in a relatively short amount
of time now the pattern kind of goes
like this over long periods of time you
see very little change as you go up the
rock layers the shells that were
uncovering haven't really changed for
long periods of time but then if some
sudden environmental change were to
occur in the next area you see some
pretty dramatic changes in the shells
they go from pretty basic to pretty
elaborate where's all the in-between
stages this would be a great example of
punctuated equilibrium and so as time
passes now these are the Schelde life
that we then see but we see long periods
with the little change and then a sudden
rapid change you know one of the best
things that could happen for mammals was
the extinction of the dinosaurs when
dinosaurs went extinct the diversity of
mammals exploded to what we see today
you
mammals were alive at the time of
dinosaurs but nothing like today the
mammals at the time of dinosaurs were
small rodents and and maybe eat insects
but now that the biggest baddest
predators on the earth have been removed
the dinosaurs we see the diversity of
mammals really take off to be what it is
and this has all happened in a
relatively short amount of time kind of
another good example of punctuated
equilibrium so one thing to mention is
that both it there are there's evidence
to support both of these patterns so it
just depends upon the situation okay so
as we wrap up this video here I want to
leave you with a practice quiz to see if
you are paying attention and if you're
in my biology class I'm happy to check
your answers before or after school one
day thanks for watching